on Israel's 70th anniversary president
Trump moves the US Embassy to Jerusalem
we talked about the left's view of
Mother's Day and America's comedians
begin to wake up I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
since magnificent day over in Israel
where President Trump was not present
but Jared Kushner Ivanka Trump a bunch
of senators a huge contingent from the
United States is over in Jerusalem
celebrating the movement of the US
Embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem that
was something that was supposed to
happen circa 1995 but various presidents
had put it up Trump finally does not
we'll talk about all of that the
implications the riots that are
happening on the border of Israel first
I want to say thanks to our sponsors
over at Birch gold so right now the
economy is doing really well thank God
it's wonderful and the dollar is very
strong which also is wonderful but
there's always volatility in the market
and this is why you should be hedging
some of your bets I mean anytime things
are going really well you should at
least have some of your money in
precious metals because you just never
know when the government starts to
inflate the currency or when there's a
bit of volatility in the market and it's
good to have that hedge that's why Birch
gold group is there they have a
long-standing track record of continued
success thousands of satisfied clients
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau you can
contact Birch gold group right now from
quest a free information kit on physical
precious metals it's a comprehensive 16
page get revealing how gold and silver
can protect your savings it can legally
move your IRA or 401k out of risky
stocks and bonds or into a precious
metals IRA to get that no-cost
no-obligation kit go to birchgold.com
slash Ben that's birchgold.com slash bad
news that slash Ben so they know that we
sent you I have some my money in
precious metals and I use the folks over
at Birch gold group for that Birch gold
group it's the place to go when you're
interested in investing in precious
metals again you know the government is
in control of the levels of currency in
circulation that's always a little bit
dangerous which is why you should at
least put some of your money in precious
metals that's what Birch gold group is
for use that slash Ben's let them know
that we sent you okay so the big story
of the day obviously is that President
Trump the Trump administration they have
now moved the US Embassy to Jerusalem
they they unveiled in this giant seals
beautiful seal Ivanka Trump Jared
Kushner they were both there they both
spoke Benjamin Netanyahu spoke at this
President Trump did not attend but he
sent a message from abroad here's what
it look like when President Trump paid
homage to the new embassy in Jerusalem
today we officially opened the United
States Embassy in Jerusalem
congratulations it's been a long time
coming
Israel is a sovereign nation
with the right like every other
sovereign nation to determine its own
capital yet for many years we fail to
acknowledge the obvious the plain
reality that Israel's capital is
Jerusalem and we extend a hand in
friendship
to Israel the Palestinians and to all of
their neighbors may there be peace may
God bless this embassy may God bless all
who served there and may God bless the
United States of America okay Benjamin
Netanyahu the Prime Minister of Israel
he also spoke and so it was very
grateful obviously the president Trump
for making this move again this had been
approved by Congress as early as 1995 so
for 23 years okay it has been the law of
the land in the United States that they
come that the embassy was supposed to
move to Jerusalem Clinton chickened out
George V bush chickened out Barack Obama
chickened out Donald Trump did not and
finally the embassy was in fact moved to
Jerusalem which is just a recognition of
simple facts the only reason anyone
cares about Jerusalem or has ever cared
about Jerusalem is because the Jews
cared about Jerusalem first Hera's
Benjamin Netanyahu Prime Minister of
Israel talking about it we have no
better friends in the world you stand
for Israel and you stand for Jerusalem
thank you what a glorious day remember
this moment
this is history President Trump by
recognizing history you have made this
street and that obviously is true look
it's an emotional moment for anyone who
is Jewish
honestly like anyone who cares about
Judaism anyone is Christian and cares
about the New Testament anybody who
cares about the history of Jerusalem
this should be an emotional historic
moment because the reality is that the
fellow the fulfillment of Jewish control
over Jerusalem was achieved in 1967 the
fulfillment of the creation or
recreation of a Jewish state in Israel
is fulfilled in 1948 but the recognition
by the United States that this is the
reality puts to bed this idiotic myth
that somehow Jerusalem was not Jewish
okay there's an old tome utak story
about a bunch of rabbis who in the
aftermath of the destruction of the sent
the second temple or two temples in the
history of Judaism the first temple was
destroyed in 587 BCE and then it was
rebuilt just a few decades later and
then the second temple was destroyed in
70 and has never been rebuilt that was
destroyed in 70 CE II 70 AD there's a
story from the Talmud about these rabbis
who visited the site of the destruction
of the temple all these are very very
famous rabbis in Jewish law Rabban
Gamliel rabbi Eleazar Ben Azaria rabbi
Joshua and Rabbi Akiva and they there's
a story about them going up to Jerusalem
right after the destruction of the
Second Temple and they reached Mount
Scopus and they tore their garments when
they reached the Temple Mount they saw a
fox emerging from the place of the Holy
of Holies the kodesh Kadosh him the the
the place where they used to have the
Ark of the Covenant and the other rabbis
started lettuce started weeping and
Rabbi Akiva started laughing this is
from the Talmud and they said to him why
are you laughing he said why are you
weeping and they said they're more a
place so holy that it is said to have
the stranger that approaches it shall
die and now foxes traverse it why
shouldn't we weep and he said to them
here's why I laugh for it is written I
shall have bare witness for me faithful
witnesses Uriah the priest and Zakaria
the son of jariabek ayah now what is the
connection between Uriah and Zachariah
Jiraiya and Zakaria Uriah was at the
time of the first temple Zechariah was
at the time the second temple but the
Torah makes Zacharias prophesy
dependence on your ayahs prophecy with
Uriah it's written therefore because of
you Zion shall be plowed as a field with
Zachariah tis written old men and women
shall yet sit in the streets of
Jerusalem as long as your ayahs prophecy
has not been fulfilled I feared that
Zechariah's prophecy may not be
fulfilled either but now the Uriah's
prophecy has been fulfilled it is
certain that Zacharias
you'll be fulfilled in other words
there's a prophecy the temple would be
destroyed he can't have the prophecy of
the temple being rebuilt until the
temple has been destroyed with these
words they replied to makeva you have
consoled the sake of consoled this one
most famous stories in all of Tom utak
lore because the center of Judaism has
always been Jerusalem the center of
judeo-christian tradition from where
it's spring has always been Jerusalem
according to the Bible the first mention
of Jerusalem actually comes in Genesis
14 18 when Abraham meets the king of
Shalem and then in Genesis 21 22 14
Abraham names the site of his near
sacrifice of Isaac ara and that was at
the same place you put those together
Yahweh and shall aim is yerushalayim
which means Jerusalem this is the site
of David's Tower it's the site of
Solomon's Temple it's the city of
Hezekiah water tunnels have you never
been to Israel never been in Jerusalem
it's just an amazing experience you're
walking the streets that existed for a
thousand years before Jesus was walking
the earth I mean it's amazing these are
the streets that Jesus walked if you're
a Christian and for a Jew these are the
streets that were walked by they were
tried by Solomon it's an unbelievable
experience think of the oldest thing
that you know of in the United States
the oldest thing that you know of in the
United States is probably from about
1620 okay now go back 2,600 years okay
and you are talking about the stuff that
you're finding in Israel Jerusalem was
the eternal Jewish dream it is the
eternal Jewish dream the dream of a free
nation living in a land promised by God
the same dream as we have in the United
States is the dream of Israel is the
dream of Bar Kochba who revolted against
the Romans in 132 seee 60 years after
the destruction of the Second Temple and
actually used Roman coinage commenced
his own he took Roman coins can buy
these online it's really cool okay he
actually took Roman coins and he beat
the Roman coins to get rid of the logo
on the Roman coins and then over it he
put the logo of the Jewish temple with
the words for the freedom of Jerusalem
this is the dream of millions of Jews
over thousands of years Jews pray thrice
daily in 3 times a day we pray for the
restoration of Jerusalem it was the
dream of Mordechai Anielewicz who's the
leader of the Warsaw Ghetto Uprising who
wrote at the end of his life right
before his murdered by the Nazis the
dream of my life has risen to become
fact Jewish armed resistance and revenge
are facts I've been a witness to the
Magnificent heroic fighting of Jewish
men in battle hey I helped write the
autobiography the memoirs of a Holocaust
survivor this Holocaust survivor went
through a fence he's actually lmv Saul's
cousin he went through outfits and he
went through
raising Scott and after the war he went
to Israel he actually had a visa to the
United States he turned down the visa to
the United States to go to Israel he
walked off the boat they handed him a
gun they sent him to the front lines of
Latrun which was on the bloodiest
battles in Israeli history and he helped
establish the State of Israel doing
behind the lines who work okay the fact
that Israel even exists is a miracle the
fact that Jerusalem is in Israeli hands
is a miracle the fact that Jerusalem is
an open city where you can worship as
you choose is a miracle
okay that's only because the Jews are in
charge of Jerusalem president Trump's
decision is not just a spiritually
resonant one it's a wise one politically
because there was never going to be a
deal between Israel and its enemies
until we recognized some basic facts on
the ground Israel is not leaving
Jerusalem the Jews are not leaving
Jerusalem they never have they never
will there's been continued continuous
Jewish presence in Jerusalem literally
since the inception of Jerusalem is a
Jewish City in the book of Joshua the
notion that there was ever a time when
shoes did not live in Jerusalem or when
it was important for reasons that were
non-jewish to begin is idiotic
hey Islam only built the Dome of the
rock on the Temple Mount specifically
for the same reason that they build
mosques on top of other holy sites they
knew it was a Jewish holy site they
built a dome on top of it doesn't mean
the dome should be destroyed obviously
but it does mean that to pretend that
Islam somehow predated Judaism in this
area is historically ignorant and
ridiculous
Judaism obviously is the foundation
stone for Christianity as well anyone
who loves history anyone who loves the
judeo-christian heritage of the West has
to understand the importance of
recognizing that heritage and that
begins with the word on the stones of
Jerusalem okay history exists and truth
exists okay when when Jews sat and
mourned and they said if I forget
Jerusalem may I forget my right hand my
right hand forget its cunning hey there
you didn't they meant it they meant it
you've never been to Jerusalem
honestly everybody should take a trip to
Jerusalem it's an amazing thing hey
Jerusalem has not been forgotten and it
will not be forgotten the Jews that were
nearly wiped off the planet are now in
control of the holiest site in Judaism
the tears have indeed turned to laughter
in the Talmud it says eternity refers to
Jerusalem Jerusalem is eternal the God
who made it is eternal as well and good
for President Trump from recognizing a
basic human truth good for President
Trump from recognizing the fact that the
Jews belong in Jerusalem and Jerusalem
belongs to the Jews to pretend that
anything else is historically ignorant
now the press are historically
not only are they historically ignorant
it's hard not to call the press
anti-semitic in the way that they cover
these these stories so at the same time
they're initiating the movement of the
embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem Hamas
has initiated all of these riots all
this violence on the border of Gaza
now Gaza is in complete control chaos
hey Gaza is run by Palestinians it is
not run by the Israelis Israel has
nothing to say except for border control
about what happens in the Gaza Strip it
is a hellhole it is a hellhole because
Hamas is a terrorist group that cares a
lot more about murdering Jews than it
does about making the lives of its own
citizens better if there if anyone
wanted peace in the Palestinian
Authority or Hamas it would happen
immediately if they just said listen we
are now done with all the violence we're
finished now we're going to build up our
society let's open it up everything
would be open tomorrow that's not what's
happening if you've seen the headlines
today a lot of the headlines from the
press are all about you know 41
Palestinians killed in clashes with
Israel okay Israel is not clashing with
the Palestinians what is happening is
the camasta is delegating they are
sending a bunch of terrorists to the
border in an attempt to breach the
border it's pretty amazing I'll probably
show the proof of the two in just one
second and and I'll talk about some of
the media coverage which is just
egregious of this of the embassy move
it's it's astonishing how bad the media
coverage is and demonstrates where their
heads are at but first I want to say
thanks to our sponsors over a texture so
if you're listening to this podcast you
are addicted to information I'm addicted
to information that's why I talk so fast
because I'm trying to get you the most
information in the shortest possible
time but when you are not listening you
need to actually be reading and the way
that you do that is you go to textures
the texture is the only app that offers
unlimited access to over 200 top
magazines including people the Atlantic
time Vanity Fair New Yorker you're
talking about the best reporting the
best long-form reporting in the country
and you have access to all of it through
texture hey Ronan Farrow is breaking
stories on a daily basis over at The New
Yorker and city you having to pay for an
issue of The New Yorker every month in
state and get their all their back
issues and you can get access to their
new issues with texture okay this is
true for the Atlantic and time and
Vanity Fair with texture you get
unlimited access to those 200 top
magazines and their back issues in a
single app anytime you want to explore
one you can and if you sign up right now
at texture comm slash Ben you get a 7
day free trial so texture calm slash man
try it free for seven days see if you
like it I promise you will to start that
free trial again go to texture comm
slash Ben to start reading the latest
shoes of your favorite magazines today
and the list is really long so you
should go over to texture and check it
out because it really is everything from
your favorite sports magazines your
favorite workout magazines all of it is
their texture calm / menus that / pens
they know that we sent you can get that
7-day free trial ok so now onto the
media coverage about the situation in
Jerusalem so quickly before I talk about
the media coverage in Jerusalem there's
a headline from the New York Times The
New York Times is egregiously
anti-israel they've been egregiously
anti-israel as long as I have been alive
and probably longer and there's an
amazing headline it says from David helm
held finger pain he writes Israel feels
pride but senses peril as u.s. moves
embassy and the and they're talking
about how it's it's really it's really
dangerous time for Israel and people are
really nervous about Israel ok here's
what it actually looks like in Israel
okay I need to show you this tape of
what it looks like in Israel right now
I'm Malkin al-huda this is clip 9 yeah
clearly people there are very torn about
the situation in Israel on the 70th
anniversary of its independence again
literally literally thousands of people
cheering in the streets of maconnais who
- Makani Judah is the biggest market
place in Jerusalem it's the street that
is completely filled and look that is so
typical of Israel right you see Orthodox
Jews and then if you see in the
background there you see an Israeli flag
mixed with a gay flag ok Israel is a
pretty diverse place pretty amazing
diverse place if you haven't visited you
really should I keep saying that but it
really is true
I was married there my wife this Israeli
her family is Israel last time we were
there actually is about 10 years ago
what we're gonna have to go trip I think
I think we're gonna have to take a trip
to Israel bring some my listeners along
so I think that would be just a blast
but the coverage of the situation in the
Gaza Strip is totally incredible and
totally biased against Israel so here is
the headline from The Washington Post
headline from The Washington Post
Israelis killed dozens of Palestinians
in Gaza protesting u.s. embassy moved to
Jerusalem well if you just read that
headline you might assume that Israelis
are killing protesters about the u.s.
embassy that people are just protesting
in the streets they're a little upset
and Israel's going out there and
slaughtering them out on us that is not
what is happening what is happening is
Hamas sent 40,000 people to the border
with Israel they're attempting to walk
across the border they're sending kites
that are on fire
across the border an attempt to start
brush fires in Israel they're throwing
Molotov cocktails and soldiers that are
throwing rocks at soldiers they're
hiding behind women and children's who
do so
this is what camasta is because they are
a terrorist group so that Washington
Post story is headline Israelis kill
dozens of Palestinians in Gaza
protesting u.s. embassy moved to
Jerusalem this is in the article itself
well some said they would abide by
official calls to keep the
demonstrations peaceful others talked
about their enthusiasm to break into
Israel and wreak havoc we are excited to
stormy get inside said 23 year old
Mohammed mansoura when asked what he
would do inside Israel he said whatever
is possible to kill throw stones does
that sound a lot like a bunch of
peaceful protesters at the border no it
doesn't because they aren't a bunch of
peaceful protesters at the border it's a
bunch of people trying to invade Israel
and Israel is repelling that and by the
way I have the evidence that Israel
isn't wholesale slaughtering people the
evidence is that Israel has complete
ground and air superiority if they
wanted a wholesale slaughter forty
thousand people they would they've got
like 40 people who are attacking the
border hey more headlines from the Gaza
Strip in just one second so here they
are ok so this is from The Jerusalem
Post some 35,000 Palestinians were
reported by the IDF as taking part in
violent protests at 12 different
locations along the fence throwing
stones explosive devices and Molotov
cocktails at the fence and IDF troops
burning tires and other burning objects
with the intention of setting fires in
Israeli territory by the way the burning
of the tires is creating enormous
environmental havoc in the Gaza Strip
itself a bunch of Palestinians are sick
because of all of this The Jerusalem
Post witnessed at least six incendiary
kites with two setting fires two fields
near a kibbutz and a hollows so really
in really using the power of
inventiveness are the Palestinians under
the control of Hamas sending kites laden
with fire over the border you know could
invent stuff or you could set a kite on
fire and try to kill some Jews the idea
afforded an attempted terror attack on
Monday when three armed Palestinians
laid an explosive device near Rafah on
the Gaza Israel border the IDF spokesman
brigadier general Ronan matalas he said
in an interview to army radio quote
Hamas is paying family to go to the
fence protest with Iranian money we have
intelligence the Kumasi operatives plans
use the protests to harm and even abduct
soldiers they're trying to kidnap
Israeli soldiers the whole point of this
obviously is to draw attention away from
the situation with the embassy and to
provide exactly the sort of media
coverage you saw all day today with the
split screens of Israelis celebrating
and Palestinians suffering oh it's so
rough for the Palestinians it is rough
for the Palestinians because they keep
in terrorist groups when you keep
electing the Palestinian Authority and
Islamic Jihad and Hamas to positions of
power it turns out you're gonna live in
a hellhole when you keep allowing your
government to delegate terrorists to the
border it turns out that the people on
the other side of that border may not be
too happy with you but again the way the
media cover this as though it is it is
totally Israel's fault another element
of this okay so there was a lot of talk
yesterday about clashes on the Temple
Mount on Jerusalem day so Jerusalem day
is the day when Israel liberated
Jerusalem from the rule of the turanians
it was in fact a liberation it was a
liberation because suddenly all these
sites were open to Jews and Christians
and Muslims alike gave the Temple Mount
however it was handed over to the
controlled these lana quacks so that
evil horrible israeli government you
know the Islamophobic israeli government
handed over controlled the holiest site
in the history of judaism to the muslims
hey does not jews who are control of the
day-to-day on top of the islamic on top
of the Temple Mount
instead they handed it over to the
control of the Islamic walk which
prevents Jews like me from going up on
the Temple Mount and praying yeah I'm
literally barred if I were to go to
Israel tomorrow and if I were to walk up
on the Temple Mount
I am barred from praying if I took out a
sitter I can do it anywhere else in the
world literally anywhere else on the
planet except for Islamic countries
which would punish me for being Jewish
anywhere in America I could pull out a
psalm book okay it's what it's handle
and book is and I would just pull it out
and start praying if I did that on the
Temple Mount
I will be arrested and it's exactly what
happened yesterday okay according to
eyewitnesses this is why net Jews
entered the holy site and they were
singing the Arabs were calling out
Allahu Akbar police forces that arrived
at the scene had to separate the warring
sides and move the Jews from the Temple
Mount I'm sorry it's not a warring side
for Jews to go up in the holiest site in
Judaism and say thank you to God but
this is illegal in Israel here the
Jerusalem police said several Jewish
visitors broke the rules of conduct and
created provocation hey this is how
sensitive Israel is the concerns of the
Islamic population living in Israel
they're so sensitive to those concerns
that Jews are not allowed to pray on the
Temple Mount for fear of provoking
Muslims okay this is actual antia and
like honestly if this were proposed this
were done in Saudi Arabia you'd call it
anti-semitic policy the idea that Jews
are not allowed to pray on a
historically Jewish surface because it
might tick off Muslims but this has been
the record of Muslims in the region
radical Muslims in the region for
this is why when everyone tries to drop
moral equivalence between what Israel is
doing in in Jerusalem and what Israel is
doing in Israel and what Hamas is doing
in the Gaza Strip or what the
Palestinian Authority are doing well
even the Islamic walk is doing it's just
insane it's just insane and ridiculous
but again none of this is is designed to
be objective media coverage all of it is
designed to pretend that Israel is the
aggressor in a conflict in which Israel
is clearly not the aggressor Israel is
clearly clearly not the aggressor in
this conflict it never was the aggressor
Israel accepted the deal in 1947 from
the UN it was attacked by Arab states
Israel in 1956 was blockaded from the
Suez Canal and they and they won that
war - in 1967 there was a pre-emptive
attack that was launched by Israel as
all of its borders were were were about
to be attacked by Islamic countries in
1973 there was an attack on Yom Kippur
the the most holy day in Judaism and it
very came very near to wiping out the
State of Israel in 1982 Lebanon was
using Hezbollah in order to in order to
strike at Israel Israel has constantly
been a defensive war since its inception
and the media keep covering as though
Israel is the aggressor in the same way
they cover America as though America is
the aggressor which shows that the
leftism of the American media and the
international media expands to a hatred
for the State of Israel they hate the
State of Israel because Israel is an
outpost of the West they don't hate the
West because of the West backs Israel
okay meanwhile yesterday was was
Mother's Day to switch topics and I
couldn't help myself one of the things
that I find absolutely just appalling
and astonishing on a regular basis is
the amazing amazing silliness of the
left when it comes to sacred times in
our in our national calendar I'm you'll
explain that in just a second first I
want to say thanks to our sponsors over
at keep so you're probably losing your
hair okay dudes you're probably seeing
your hair chances are you are you're
probably not paying attention to it even
if you're young but if you look at your
dad if your dad has losses here you're
probably gonna lose your hair as well so
that is why it is necessary for you to
talk to my friends over at keeps hey
there is a real solution to hair loss
but you have to do it now it can't you
can't wait until all the hair falls out
then you say you're gonna get some
miracle grow and sprinkle it on your
head that ain't gonna work
there are two clinically proven
medications that let you keep your hair
and now they are inexpensive and easy to
Kay you don't need to lose your hair if
you don't want to which is why keeps
exist for five minutes now in just one
buck a day you'll never have to worry
about hair
again getting started with keeps is
really easy so you sign up and it takes
less than five minutes
just answer a few questions snap some
photos I've done this a licensed doctor
remotely reviews her information
recommends the right treatment for you
all without ever leaving your couch they
offer generic versions / it keeps them
the only two fda-approved hair loss
products out there you've probably tried
them before you never got them this easy
for this price keeps it's only 10 bucks
to 35 bucks a month and now you can get
your first month for free that's a
pretty great deal for getting to keep
your hair longer so go over to keeps
calm / Ben you get your first month of
treatment for free keeps calm / Ben ke
EPS calm / Ben again these are the same
medications your doctor will be
prescribing something I can do it from
the comfort of your own home and it's a
lot cheaper
goto keeps calm / Ben that's ke EPS ke
EPS calm / menus that slash pen to keep
your hair okay so I have some great news
that I'm excited to share with you right
now
okay this is this news that I am
breaking right now we are finally taking
the Ben Shapiro show in front of a live
audience which is just awesome are you
excited are you excited you should be
because it's gonna be awesome this
August I'm going to be doing my podcast
live in Dallas and Phoenix and you will
be able to see me in person and join me
in an audience Q&A and we'll be also
doing a special VIP event beforehand
with a signing and a meet-and-greet for
200 superfans so I can't wait to see you
visit dailyrx.com slash events for more
information here's the best part
if you're a premium subscriber you can
get tickets pre-sales starting tomorrow
morning Tuesday May 15th 10:00 a.m. in
every time zone so check it out Tuesday
May 15 10:00 a.m. in every time zone if
you're a subscriber you can be the first
person to buy a VIP ticket a regular
ticket if you aren't a subscriber well
then you should subscribe people and you
should get a beautiful leftist cheers
tumblr and get early access to tickets
but you have to hurry because this is
only going to last until 10:00 p.m. on
Thursday May 17th once again visit
dailyrx.com slash events to get your
presale tickets and additional info ok
so go check that out it's gonna be
awesome I can't wait to see you out
there become a subscriber ok it's really
totally worth it there's just one reason
why I should do it ok so meanwhile
yesterday it was Mother's Day and
Mother's Day is always a weird time if
you're on the left I have to imagine
it's kind of a weird time if you're on
the left because the left likes to
proclaim that they love Mother's Day oh
I'm gonna go out for mimosas with mom
for brunch for Mother's Day here's one
of the things that's weird about leftist
patterns of thought so a lot of folks on
the left they'd like to proclaim that
certain things in America are sacrosanct
Parenthood children apple-pie mothers
but then when it comes to their actual
ideology they're kind of anti a lot of
those things when it comes to mothers
for example mothers are seen as Stooges
of the patriarchy by a lot of radical
feminists if you are a woman and you
choose to stay home and mother your
children this makes you a bad person you
are a lesser person you've been sucked
into the maw of the patriarchy that is
chewed you up and spit you out and
suggested that you must indeed be a
woman barefoot and pregnant in the
kitchen rather than running companies
rather than having a job okay if you're
a stay-at-home mom you're a bad person
according to a lot of folks on the left
but then when it comes Mother's Day
Mother's Day I love Mother's Day you
can't have it both ways if you think
mothers are rubes and you can't you
can't celebrate Mother's Day plus you
got a bunch of folks on the left and I
would say the majority of the left now
that suggests that a child doesn't need
a mother now I believe a child doesn't
your mother a child needs a mother and a
father and this is why I always tweet
out on Mother's Day happy parent Apple a
happy legal guardian unspecified gender
day because if you are on the left this
is what you believe you believe that you
can have a legal guardian of any gender
whatsoever you can have a mother who's a
father a father who's a mother a mother
who used to be a father a father who
used to be a mother who used to be a
chicken any of these things are possible
so why not just call it legal guardian
specified gender day but no but then the
left gets mad when you say this because
it shows that they're really not super
Pro mom is a general rule you know the
whole were in favor of abortion and we
think that women are stupid if they stay
home with their kids and also a child
doesn't need a mother a child brought up
by wolves or any other family
arrangement is totally fine Mowgli had
it best you know all of this and then
they say we love Mother's Day hey you
can't again you can't have it both ways
you can't say that you hold certain
things sacrosanct when you clearly do
not hold them sacrosanct the same thing
is true of the innocence of children the
same people who will say you have to
protect innocent children from video
games you have to protect innocent
children from the predations
of their church-going parents these are
the same people who say then a
four-year-old should be seeing a
psychiatrist to get hormone treatment to
prevent puberty and these are the same
folks okay so anyway I tweeted some of
this stuff out yesterday and a lot of
people on the Left have very very mad
okay a lot of people say yeah how could
I just room Mother's Day by pointing out
that a lot of folks on the Left don't
really have a reason to celebrate
Mother's Day hey and then I did
something even worse yesterday I did
something even worse on Mother's Day so
I asked my this is actually a funny
story so yesterday morning I woke up and
my daughter woke me up I went in there
to her room gave her a big hug and she
said what day is it today I said well
Sunday and it's Mother's Day we're gonna
do some special stuff for mommy isn't
that fun
and she said yeah and then I said
sweetheart you're gonna when you grow up
you can't you're gonna have a job and
you're also gonna be a mommy which one
of those things do you think is probably
gonna be more fun and she said being a
mommy so I can cuddle my babies which is
really cute right clearly she's a victim
of the patriarchy because if she knew
best she would know that working a long
2,200 billable hours a year job as an
associate of Law Firm is significantly
more fun than cuddling baby's clearly
she would know this by the way I would
assume that if I asked my son this when
he's old enough not to be pooping in his
diapers if I asked him this I assume
he'll give me the same answer cuz being
a dad is super fun we need more parents
male and female who are interested in
raising their children rather than
making their career first priority that
would be great
you know my career is very very
important to me I think that every day I
get up and I'm eager to go to work but
I'm even more eager to spend time with
my kids I probably spend more time with
my kids at this point that my wife does
because she's in medical residency as as
I may have mentioned once or twice she's
a doctor so anyway I tweeted this out I
tweeted out I asked my four-year-old
this morning whether she thought it'd be
more fun to have a job or be a mommy she
said to be a mommy so I can cuddle my
babies clearly she has already been
victimized by the patriarchy and I said
I would begin teaching her in order to
counter man the demands of the
patriarchy I'd begin teaching her the
babies are made out of thorns and hatred
and that she can work as an executive at
Willy Wonka's chocolate factory and that
will somehow make it all better a bunch
of people have got really mad number one
they misinterpreted the tweet to assume
that what I was saying is that she could
either have a job or be a mommy witch
yes that's me all over right I'm the guy
who says women can't have jobs except
for how my mom worked in my dad stayed
at home and my wife works and I stay at
home except for all of that you got me
spot on spot on I'm the guy who forces
my wife to be a doctor yes clearly
you've pegged me correctly leftists and
people on the Left got very angry though
because if you point out a very simple
truth hey that little girls want to be
mommies they get so mad they get so
angry if you say little girls naturally
want to be mommies and have babies of
their own no no that is a gender
construct
that is something that you had to teach
them never mind
hundreds of thousands of years of human
biology never mind all an animal kingdom
biology don't mind any of that stuff
it was clearly that five guys got in a
room several thousand years ago and they
said we have to convince women it's good
to have babies we have to convince them
of this now we should also never mind
all the fact that all these all these
feminist women hit the age of 40 and
they start freezing their eggs because
they're afraid they're not gonna be able
to have kids we should not be a we
should we should ignore the fact that a
lot of women turn around at age 35 after
having being told that they could have
everything the career and the and the
children and think man I wish that I had
spent a little more time at home we
should ignore all of those things
instead we should we should pretend that
all of this is is a construct that is
unnatural for women to want babies girls
want babies little girls want to have
babies and when my daughter plays games
my daughter's games she was doing it
last night there's a giant Barney that
we have in our house a giant Barney doll
that we have in our house my daughter
made a bed for her giant Barney and then
she said my giant Barney is sick and I
want to take care of my giant Barbie
Barney because he is my baby my son
takes a bat and hits the giant Barney
okay there are different children
because boys are not the same as girls
so stupid but if you acknowledge this
then it's somehow bad but here's the
problem if you don't acknowledge this
and why you're celebrating Mother's Day
if you're not pretending that it's
innate to women to want to be mothers if
you're not per se if you're not
suggesting that women have something
special to offer in the realm of
parenthood then why are we celebrating
Mother's Day in the first place I love
it so Elizabeth spires who's a feminist
idiot she tweeted out the fact that you
framed it to her as an either/or is the
problem Ben and and I tweeted back well
I didn't frame it as an either/or I say
I said which one is more fun okay if I
said when you grow up which do you think
will be more fun going to a baseball
game or going to work I'm not suggesting
that you can only go to baseball games
and never go to work I'm suggesting that
there's a hierarchy of fun and it
actually is an important question so
here's the here's the punchline so it's
really funny I told my wife about this
yesterday we were in the car and we're
driving to Disneyland with the kids and
I turned to my wife and I told her this
story and she says oh that's really
funny because you know what I asked my
daughter I asked I asked my our daughter
the same question last night it's I
asked her I don't you know there's my
wife again
the doctor who turned to my daughter
last night and she said okay this is it
this is a closed paraphrase and she said
you know mommy loves being a doctor but
mommy loves being your mommy even more
than that a lot more than that if mommy
mommy wants to spend more time with you
okay is she part of the patriarchy now
my wife this is so stupid
okay all of this is so dumb but the same
lepton wants to obliterate gender
differences and then celebrate gender
differences you can't do both obliterate
them or celebrate them you can't
obliterate them and then celebrate them
you can't pretend men and women are
exactly the same with exactly the same
aspirations hopes and dreams and then
say that women are unique creatures who
deserve special days like Mother's Day
all of this is just yeah and I love this
so dictionary.com actually tweeted out
at me fallacy any of the various types
of erroneous reason that render
arguments logically unsound Thank You
dictionary.com I'm so glad that you
define fallacy for me in turn at
dictionary.com whose life's work is to
tweet out definitions written by others
hundreds of years ago you dolt
hey I did not say that my daughter
should not get a job I've told her by
the way that she could be President of
the United States and you know what she
you know what she responded she said
that sounds really boring
can't argue can't argue with that okay
so I want to talk a little bit about
this this whole McCain apology thing in
just a second first you're gonna have to
go over to Daley we're not come and
subscribe so at Daley wire calm you get
the rest of this show live and again
when you're a subscriber you get tickets
right you get you're gonna get your
chance to get tickets thousands of
people who think like you or who don't
think like you can ask questions it'll
be great
you get to go backstage we can only buy
your tickets early if you're a
subscribers from $9.99 a month get a
subscription get any annual subscription
and you get this as well the leftist
year's hot or cold tumbler and that also
allows you to ask questions in our
mailbag on Fridays plus it also allows
you to ask questions to Michael Mills so
tomorrow Tuesday May 15 5:30 p.m.
Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific it is time for
our next episode of the conversation our
own Michael Mills the execrable he is
going to be answering all of your
questions I don't know what sort of
answers he can give you beyond weird
stories about the stuff he did in his
spare time at Yale but if you like that
sort of thing then Michael Mills can
answer our questions tomorrow
Alicia Krauss will be there to keep
Knolls in line ensure that he keeps his
shirt on which is the task of half the
office these days
this month episode will stream live on
telly where it's YouTube and Facebook
pages it's free for everyone to watch
only subscribers can ask the questions
so go check it out to ask questions as a
subscriber you go over to daily we're
calm and then you log in and then you go
over to the conversation and watch it
and then you can just start typing
questions in and Michael will answer
your questions as they come in for an
entire hour so subscribe to get those
questions answered also subscribe right
now because tomorrow the tickets go on
sale they're going to sell out we know
they will so just go there and get your
subscription it ain't that expensive to
get a subscription of the daily wire and
you get those special tickets early you
get them a lot earlier than everybody
else so go check it out
right now also that helps us bring you
the show it helps us make sure we're
bringing you great content and yesterday
if you haven't listened to it we brought
out our Sunday special with with Dave
Rubin our first episode was Jordan
Peterson our second episode was Dave
Rubin and next week we have a special
guest who is just as awesome we have a
special guest every week who's just as
interesting and just as awesome also
please go over to Daley we'll go over to
Apple News and check out daily wire over
at Apple News as well
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so meanwhile there's a big hubbub
that has arisen over John McCain so John
McCain is unfortunately extremely sick
and he is likely to pass away sometime
in the next few months he has brain
cancer and it's it's really sad whatever
you think of John McCain John McCain is
is I think I mean there's no question
he's an American patriot I'm the man
suffered horrific torture and then
served for decades in the Senate trying
to do what he thought was was right I
disagree with him a lot of politics
everything from campaign finance reform
Medicaid Part D I agree I disagree with
him on many many policies I thought that
his 2008 run for the presidency was
lackluster
none of that has to do with who he is as
a patriot and his contributions to the
country okay so there is a big story
that broke late last week bad for the
Trump administration there's a woman
named named Sadler who apparently in
some meeting her name is Kelly Sadler
and she apparently in a meeting at the
White House was asked about the fact
that McCain was going to vote against
Gina Haspel Gina Haspel is of course
Donald Trump's nominee for CIA to head
the CIA and apparently during the
meeting she joked that somebody was
gonna that that who cares he's gonna die
anyway right and then this leaked so
there are two issues here okay issue
here number one is what she said and
issue number two is leaked so what she
said is obviously horrible right it's a
horrible joke clearly and that raised
some questions about the people in the
room because we've all been in meetings
where somebody's making horrible jokes
but we all know where the lines are
right so we have meetings here at this
office where people are making dumb
horrible jokes but the certain jokes
that you won't make even among your
friends because they're just too
egregious and just too yucky this is a
joke that you wouldn't make among your
friends okay well you know John McCain
is gonna die soon it's just yeah you you
don't make a joke about a dying man
particularly not a patriot and and so
obviously that's that's pretty terrible
and it says something about the people
in the room that this sort of went
unnoticed or unremarked upon and
apparently no one tried at her or that
she felt comfortable enough to say it in
the first place suggests that maybe
people at the White House say some stuff
that they shouldn't be saying on a
pretty regular basis but that's not a
shock I mean Donald Trump said in the
middle of the campaign and then John
McCain was not a war hero because he'd
been captured so it says something about
the the moral fish rotting from the head
when it comes to bad the same bad stuff
about others and then there's the
question
liek so people on the right who have
been pointing out that it is not good
that the administration leaks this much
they've been they've been shellacked
over the weekend how why are you so
worried about who'll eats the Sadler
conversation why aren't you more worried
about what she said well I can be
worried about both I can talk about the
moral lack in saying that John McCain's
gonna die soon but I can also worry
about the fact that there's a White
House so leaky but the way that you take
down your political opponents who
supposedly are working for the same
goals that you are is to leak the nasty
stuff that they said in a conversation
there's a certain level of trust that
has to exist in any office environment
you know this you work in an office I
work in an office there's a certain
level of trust and the truth is that
people make
what would widely be construed as
inappropriate jokes all the time now
this may be beyond the pale
inappropriate but how many inappropriate
jokes do we make a day here at the daily
office a thousand I mean a lot of
inappropriate jokes I'm not talking
racist jokes or anything but I'm talking
about jokes that if you printed them in
the pages within the New York Times
people go oh that's weird why would they
make that joke okay that sort of stuff
happens all the time at offices all
around the country and it would be kind
of bad for your business if it turned
out that every time somebody made a joke
that would read a lot worse than it
would speak then that would sort of make
the front pages of New York something
bad for your business and that John
Mulaney has a comedy special where he
talks specifically about this where
apparently one of his friends and was it
one of his friends was in trouble with
with the law because somebody had was
testifying against them in a civil case
and John Mulaney wrote a funny email
back that said something like that
something want me to kill them for you
that's a joke and then he's jokes about
the fact that if that had been read in
court that would be a real problem for
him right because suddenly we'd be read
in court at the John Mulaney wanted to
kill somebody that sort of stuff happens
at your business every day
I think this falls under that category
meaning it's something bad that was said
but now it's being turned into a
national issue now obviously the proper
solution to this is for Kelly salvo to
come out and say I shouldn't have said
it
obviously it was it was a poor joke I
never should have said anything like
this
instead it's instead because the White
House has a habit of never backing down
never apologizing she continues not to
apologize publicly for this even though
she called up Megan McCain that
apologized privately Bernie Sanders was
asking why the White House won't
apologize to McCain I do have a theory
and shake it is beyond my comprehension
it is one thing in the white house for
somebody to say something crude and
stupid and disrespectful an American
Hero
it is another thing for them not to
apologize so it is beyond my
comprehension I just don't know what
goes on in that White House mentality
for there not being an apology for that
terrible remark okay so Bernie Sanders
he says that the people in the White
House should obviously apologize the
reason that the people in the white
house aren't apologizing is because they
have a basic rule never compromise never
apologize never apologize because
they're just going to bang you over the
head about it now I don't think that
rule is actually true I don't think it's
true that if you just came forward you
said yep never should have said it you
take flak for about a day and then it
would be done but I understand the
tendency on the part of some people in
the White House that tendency to say
listen I'm not going to bend over
backwards in order to apologize to
people who are just going to shellac me
for it anyway we're just gonna crush me
for it anyway I know that's Donald
Trump's tendency and he's been very
successful with it in this particular
case it seems to me the sadler should
just come forward and apologize that
said I think anybody who is found to
have leaked this stuff to the press
should be fired if I were a head of the
Trump administration I'd be firing
nearly everybody in that room because
you can't have a working business
environment which people are leaking
like this I mean while there's something
weird that's beginning to happen in
comedy land so a lot of the comedian's
are beginning to realize that maybe the
making fun of Trump thing is actually
kind of counterproductive which it is
it's so funny the left dominance of the
cultural Heights their dominance in the
world of comedy their dominance in the
world of entertainment media it's made
them think they're a lot more powerful
than they actually are it's why at the
DNC some people like Lena Dunham up
there on stage the Lena Dunham was going
to swing votes of anybody who wasn't
already living in big cities and and
watching girls they really think that
their dominance of the cultural Heights
means dominance of the political heights
but what you've actually seen is that
Republicans in many ways are dominant to
an extraordinary degree in politics and
Democrats are extraordinarily dominant
at the degree of culture and this is not
a coincidence I think the dominance of
Democrats in culture is driving the
Republican dominance in politics the
fact that so many people around the
country feel constantly derided and
insulted by the media it makes them feel
like fine I'll just vote Republican fine
you're gonna label me a jerk I'm just
gonna go vote how you don't want me to
vote anyway because I don't like you
either there's a lot of that going
around and it seems to like a lot of the
comedians are starting to figure this
out so Jimmy Kimmel Pope Jimmy he has
decided that America might be tired in
fact of the bashing of Donald Trump that
maybe this has been a maybe this has
been a mistake so he did an interview he
did an interview with with the upfront
and he said sometimes there's such
low-hanging fruit you have to choose
between 12 jokes on one subject and
picking the right ones is something I
obsess over then I found two that almost
inevitably my best jokes come to me
around 3:00 in the morning when I'm
sitting there alone but then he admitted
that perhaps they have gone a little bit
too far and he says he says I hadn't
really thought about it that way but I
guess you're right hopefully it'll be
the last up front of the Trump era - so
I don't know how much focus will be on
there I think people have had an ass
full of Donald Trump and I feel like the
up front is the time to look within and
make fun of ourselves he says that he
can't imagine the up fronts are gonna be
completely Trump free but he's planning
on not making it his focus he's saying
that he might actually be moving beyond
beyond a lot of the of the Trump stuff
because people are just tired of the
Donald Trump stuff well the reason
people are tired of the Trump stuff is
because you weren't even handed about it
during the Obama era it is amazing that
so many of these comedians seem to
ignore the fact that Obama was an
inherently funny human being as well
because he was so pretentious Donald
Trump is an inherently funny being
because Donald Trump is Donald Trump but
a lot of people are beginning to
recognize this is a mistake Saturday
Night Live they're recognizing now that
political stuff is beginning to get a
little bit old do you like the show
right look I do remember I was in that
production of The Crucible in high
school right yeah you know the principal
is a lot like witch-hunt against
President Chuck okay don't look that
let's go enough with the Trump jokes
mom I don't write those and why doesn't
us now ever talk about crooked Hillary
mom I'm so new here please do not do
this to me okay and this is exactly
right okay SNL may begin maybe maybe the
comedians are beginning to get it would
you actually be bad news for Republicans
as the Republican yes it's irritating to
watch Michelle what's-her-face go off at
the at the White House Correspondents
Dinner on Sarah Huckabee Sanders yes
watching her make abortion jokes is
going but as a conservative yes you need
more of this right you need is more of
these comedians being idiots well you
need is more of the comedians who are
wildly biased
because it's driving people into the
Republican camp well good news there
still Trump Renault so Trevor Noah can't
be central he says the president Trump
is like an African dictator he is just
like an African dictator is just like
Mugabe right because he's seizing a lot
of people's money and because he's
redistributing land and probably because
he's killing all of his enemies wait
how's he like an African dictator again
Trevor not explained I said from the
very beginning that Donald Trump reminds
me of an African dictator and if you
know anything about African dictators
the first thing you have to do is follow
the money and you follow the money with
the people closest to them family
members business associates all you do
is watch for the money and I would have
been disappointed had we not found out
or had Michael Cohen not done this I'm
like yeah this is following the script
this is what you were meant to be doing
as the person who roles with Donald
Trump you were always going to be
finding a way to swindle cash one of the
things that's extraordinarily going
about this of course is that this is
Trevor Noah on CNN with brian Stelter
one of the things a lot of these comic
figures like to do is play the clown
nose on clown nose off routine so the
minute they say something controversial
to go hey I'm just a comedian I can say
whatever I want why are you taking me
seriously hey I'm a comic and then Jimmy
Kimmel will go out there with his sick
child and talk about his sick child and
use the sick child as an excuse for
revamping health care or Trevor Noah
will go on CNN and give his political
tank listen you want to be both that's
fine you're gonna get treated like a
pundit and that means that we're going
to critique you like a pundit this is
idiotic every politician in American
history of any prominence or amend most
of them I would say have had family
connections with serious corruption
involved just ask bills siblings just
ask Hillary Clinton ask Hugh Rodham
ask the Kennedys and all of the the the
idea that Donald Trump is like an
African dictator is such a wild
exaggeration wild stupidity no wonder
people are not taking some folks on the
Left seriously when they look at it
folks like Trevor Noah or Jimmy Kimmel
as political lights to follow okay time
for some things I like things I hate
then we'll do a Federalist paper real
fast so things I like since it is in
fact a celebrity day for Jerusalem I'm
gonna play you the most beautiful song
ever written about Jerusalem this is a
song called yerushalaim shel zahav so
it's in Hebrew it's called Jerusalem
Jerusalem is made of gold Jerusalem of
Gold is the literal translation and the
singer on this
I'm trying member her name it's
Oprah huzzah huzzah yeah Oprah huzzah
she was in I'm her voice and Prince of
Egypt she sings the she sings one of the
parts in Prince of Egypt there's an old
tape a really tragic story I think she
died of like hepatitis when she's like
42 through a blood transfusion it's
really terrible but she but but this
rendition a beautiful I'm shel zahav is
quite beautiful I use it very often when
I'm cause on at my shul so at my at my
synagogue
I sometimes pray for the congregation
when I do that is a song that I like to
use the tune of for from the various
prayers so here is here's the song just
a beautiful song
[Music]
Yamaha
Oh
[Music]
mission
[Applause]
[Music]
so it's a beautiful song that the lyrics
mean the mountain air is clear as water
the sense of pines around is carried on
the breeze of Twilight and tinkling
bells resound the trees and stones their
softly slumbers a dream unfolds them all
so solitary lies the city and at its
heart a wall o Jerusalem of gold and of
light and of bronze I am the loot for
all your songs it's a beautiful
beautiful song and she's actually a
terrific singer Oh for a huzzah so you
should check out her work on mine as
well okay time for some quick things
that I hate so Hillary Clinton is a mad
at everybody again I'm just gonna go
around the rest of her life being angry
which I think might not actually be that
much of a change for it seems like she
spent most of her life being angry at
something or other now she's still angry
at the American public and saying that
they are sexist she says there's still a
very large portion of the population
that is uneasy with women in positions
of leadership and so the easiest way to
kind of avoid having to look at someone
on her merits is dismiss her on her
looks yes I'm sure that's why you lost
it's not because you're deeply
off-putting on every conceivable level
it's because people don't like the way
that you look if you're a beautiful
woman I'm sure you would have won
Hillary Clinton except for the fact that
no and there's this amazing study who's
really funny where they took the debate
between the first debate between Trump
and Hillary Clinton and they reversed
the sexist they had a guy read all of
Hillary Clinton's lines and a woman read
all Donald Trump's lines and then they
had people evaluate the debate they
people who are they're sitting there
with with the dials trying to determine
who won and turns out that Trump as a
woman won by more of a margin than Trump
is a man because Hillary's personality
is so off-putting that it doesn't matter
whether she's a man or a woman she's
just that amount of off-putting which is
pretty amazing okay other things that I
hate so Benedict Cumberbatch has now
said that he's gonna turn down a role
unless his unless his co-star is paid
the same amount of money that he is
that's because internet feminists were
very angry that Bryce Dallas Howard was
paid two million dollars less then Chris
Pratt was for the new Jurassic Park
movie of course she was paid less
because no one cares of price tell us
how it is in those movies it sure just
if you were to disappear tomorrow and
suddenly be replaced by by Jessica
Chastain like just another redhead then
no one would care right would even like
if that happened when people even notice
really not the Bryce Dallas Howard isn't
a good actress but she doesn't do
anything in those movies she's not the
start of the film was Chris Pratt is the
star of the films I'm happy to pay Bryce
Dallas Howard
like a great acting job but she is not
the draw of those movies benedict
cumberbatch however he's now trying to
say that equal pay and a place at the
table out of the central tenets of
feminism look at your quotas ask what
women are being paid and say if she's
not paid the same as men I'm not doing
it and he says that he has a new
production company that is female
focused now I don't hate this because he
is because he's doing this good for him
that's fine you know but what I do hate
is the implication that any man who's
not doing this is somehow shortchanging
women that's ridiculous
hey Benedict Cumberbatch is gonna have
to take less pay to do this end of story
if he actually and because no one is
gonna pay he look he's the star of
Doctor Strange I mean no one is going to
pay whatever random female co-star of
the next Doctor Strange movie is the
same amount they're gonna pay Benedict
Cumberbatch not unless Benedict
Cumberbatch takes less pay because the
reality is that if he asks for five
million dollars and I can't pay some
some female lead who's gonna be in them
one movie the same amount I think there
is a market to this stuff Jennifer
Lawrence makes a lot of money women in
film make a lot of money I do love the
people the upper end of the income
bracket complaining about income
inequality it's pretty amazing so if you
wants to take a pay cut good for him
that's it that's well within his rights
they did that on friends by the way that
all the people who are the stars and
friends they want to pay some more and
others less and they got together and I
believe they pooled their income and
said okay we're all gonna be paid the
same amount of money that's cool good
for Benedict Cumberbatch on that level
but again if the implication is the
Chris Pratt is doing something deeply
horribly wrong by taking more money than
the Bryce Dallas Howard may be sure how
to get a better agent or maybe sure to
pick better script okay time for the
time from Federalist paper real fast so
Federalist number 28 every week we go
through a federalist paper where all the
way up to Federalist number 28 Alexander
Hamilton writes this one he wrote the
vast majority of them he continues with
his arguments about the strength of the
national government with an army under
the control of the legislature so
there's a lot of debate over who should
actually control the the national army
should there be a standing army a lot of
people very afraid of this because they
thought that it would suck power away
from the state and he makes one very
interesting argument he says if the
representatives of the people betrayed
their constituents the argument here is
that we can't have the legislature
control the National standing army
because if we do then this will allow
the legislature to run roughshod over
the state so how Alexander Hamilton
writes if the representatives of the
people betray their constituents there's
then no resource left but in the
exertion of that original
right of self-defense which is paramount
to all positive forms of government and
which against the usurpations of the
national rulers may be exerted with
infinitely better prospect of success
than against those of the rulers of an
individual state he's talking about the
right to resist okay so for all the
people out there on the Left who say
that there was no inherent right to
resist there's no right to bear arms
keeping bear arms for use against the
government Alexander Hamilton is
explicitly talking about that he's
talking about if the legislature were to
usurp the powers of the people the
people would stand up and the reason you
want a national standing army as opposed
to state standing armies is because it
is actually harder to fight against a
state standing army than it is to have
the state to act as the go-between for a
battle against the national government
in reality that's exactly what happened
during the Civil War it's a lot bloodier
because whose national national
government versus the States but the
argument here is even deeper than that
and that is that you do have a natural
right to resist a government that
usurped your fundamental rights and if
the government does usurp your
fundamental rights that's the reason
that you need to keep in bear arms as a
root as a root cause okay so we will be
back here tomorrow with all of the
latest on Ben Shapiro
but first sorry before I let go sorry
before I let go I want to remind you
remind you that if you want to get
tickets we're doing this show live we
are doing it live and we're gonna do it
live like Bill O'Reilly we're gonna do
it live and we are going to it live from
Dallas and from Phoenix and you will be
there and I will see you there but if
you wanna get the tickets early you need
to go on daily wire comm right now
please subscribe it really helps us and
also it means you get the tickets early
earlier than anyone else they're only
200 VIP tickets per event those VIP
tickets mean you get to come backstage
hang with me I mean to get pictures with
me you get a goodie bag all sorts of
awesome stuff happening backstage and
you get that if you become a subscriber
and buy the tickets early so go
subscribe daily we're calm right now
check it out I'm bench Carol we'll see
you here tomorrow
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alexander Oh audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing